mit laser werden cds abgespielt wird
geschnitten operiert geschweißt und er
ist quasi eine allzweckwaffe und wird
tatsächlich inzwischen auch wenigen
tagen offiziell als waffe von der us
navy eingesetzt laser sind in der lage
ultrafeine strukturen zu erzeugen und
sogar die ultra exakte atomzeit zu
übertragen
wie wir ja letztlich hier berichtet
haben wie genau sie funktionieren und
wieso sie einigen menschen bereits zum
verhängnis wurden jetzt in kriegszeiten
fixen herzlich willkommen
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation oder kurz laser ja
das sind im grunde genommen nichts
anderes als werkzeuge um nicht mit ganz
besonderen eigenschaften zu erzeugen das
licht einer herkömmlichen glühbirne
besteht auf einer vielzahl von farben
also wellenlängen dem sogenannten
spektrum das ist zum beispiel rot oder
blau oder wollen und jede farbe hat ihre
eigene wellenlänge möchte man sich aus
diesem spektrum eine bestimmte
wellenlänge herauspicken für ist sie
es auch immer eine bestimmte farbe und
deshalb immer ausschließlich mit hilfe
von filtern möglich und silber das
bedeutet gleichzeitig das unglaublich
viele ursprünglichen leistung verloren
geht das licht wird schwächer bei einem
leser ist das aber anders er ist in der
lage licht mit nur einer wellenlänge
und gleichzeitig mit einer extrem hohen
intensität zu erzeugen doch wie genau
funktioniert das grundsätzlich besteht
jeder leser aus wenigstens drei
komponenten einer lichtquelle zwei
spiegeln und einem aktiven medium gerade
in den anfänglichen jahren der leser
entwicklung verwendet man für das
aktive medium wer gerne rubine das hat
das ganze natürlich entsprechend teuer
gemacht heutzutage werden zwar immer
noch kristalle verwendet diese werden
jedoch extra dafür gezüchtet und sind
dementsprechend preis damit ein
laserstrahl entstehen kann wird das
aktive medium zunächst von einer
lichtquelle bestrahlt die licht also
photonen aus wendet diese lichtquelle
verfügt noch über ein relativ breites
lichtspektrum beinhaltet farben also
aller frequenzen licht ist ja nichts
anderes als kleine teilchen
lichtteilchen nämlich photonen jedes
dieser winzigen photonen enthält dabei
eine bestimmte menge an energie die es
jetzt an die moleküle des kristalls
abgibt wenn der lichtstrahl dort im
kristall auf ein molekül trifft und
jetzt suchen wir auch etwas paradoxes in
der physik wir hatten das schon mal beim
doppels bald experiment wenn nicht durch
einen doppel steinfeld der lesters
dahinter auf einer fläche ein
interferenzmuster licht ist also eine
welle messe ich jedoch durch welchen
spalt das lichtfeld habe also an jedem
fall ein detektor verschwindet das
interferenzmuster und auf der fläche
ist die vielleicht etwas unscharf und
projektion von zwei schlitten zu sehen
licht besteht also auch zeichen ja das
ist schon ziemlich dazu
denn beides gilt aber beim leser wird es
genutzt das photon wird jetzt als welle
vom molekül aufgenommen sprich
lediglich die energie das photon
existiert nicht mehr
die moleküle werden so in einen
angeregten zustand überführt wir haben
mehr energie
doch diesen energieüberschuss können
wir nicht auf dauer halten und müssen
irgendwann abgeben und das machen sie
wieder als photon
allerdings geben die moleküle des
kristalls nur photonen einer bestimmten
wellenlänge ab beim rubin das größte
was bei den ersten roten lesern
eingesetzt wurde ist es rot um den rubin
oder ein anderes kristall
beziehungsweise den resonator gibt es
jetzt aber spiegel und die haben eine
ganz einfache funktion sie fangen einen
teil des lichts ein das heißt es gibt
in diesem resonators zwischen den beiden
spiegeln immer mehr lich immer mehr
photonen schießen kreuz und quer darin
herum und nehmen dann aber eine ganz
bestimmte flugrichtung 1
denn nur wenn sie zwischen den spiegeln
hin und her fliegen können sie gefangen
werden das restliche licht kann für den
prozess nicht genutzt werden
tja und jetzt passiert noch etwas auch
die von den molekülen ausgesandten
photonen treffen jetzt auf andere
moleküle und lösen dort wieder die
aussendung von photonen aus zwischen den
beiden spiegeln bleiben jetzt die
photonen gefangen
die die gleiche wellenlänge abend und
exakt zwischen den spiegeln hin und
herfliegen das ausschließlich photonen
wind die von den molekülen ausgeblendet
wurden haben sie die exakt gleichen
eigenschaften und das ist die
besonderheit leder streift alles in ihm
ist exakt gleich die wellenlänge die
lage der welle im raum also die
polarisation die richtung und wie
schwingen gleich das macht es zu einem
ganz besonderen licht und jetzt wird
dieser laserstrahl wenn sich das also
hier verstärkt hat freigelassen
nur einer der spiegel jetzt eine kleine
menge an photonen durch und zwar gerade
so viel dass der laser prozess im
saisonal tor nicht zusammenbricht diese
photonen die den resonator verlassen das
ist der laserstrahl und jetzt extrem
gefährlich er kann stahl schneiden mit
ihm kann exakter operiert werden als mit
einem skalpell und seit neuestem gibt es
laserwaffen und die nicht mehr nur in
fan fiction film journey selbst seit ein
paar tagen offiziell eine laserwaffe ein
lied so exakt wie keine waffe zuvor
jetzt
eben nicht mehr schiffe betroffen
sondern die angriffe wind chirurgisch
eine mini drohne eine rasante eine
kanone alles kann jetzt absolut exakt
getroffen werden der laser krieg hat
begonnen aber auch für uns hier sind
laser extrem gefährlich bereits wenn
sie erzeugt werden winzige zu
unglaublichen leistungen in der lage
gerät ein solcher leber strahl einen
menschen ins auge erblindet er sofort
denn die linse des auges fokussiert den
leser nochmals er wird noch
gefährlicher und zerstört die netzhaut
sofort deshalb sind nur sehr sehr
leistungsschwache leben überhaupt für
otto normalverbraucher erlaubt über die
neuen entwicklungen im bereich der
lasertechnologie halten wir euch
natürlich hier immer auf dem laufenden
wenn er kein video dazu verpassen
drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den auf die glocke hier
geht es weiter mit leser
teilchenbeschleuniger revolutioniert
weil die medizin
denn auch das ist mit lasern möglich
ein wirklich extrem spannendes projekt
welche interessiert einfach draufklicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleib dran